was haben
sie hier und er und er gemeinsam genau
sie alle waren mal afg vorsitzende air
kino kubala ist das vielleicht demnächst
auch in der afg gibt es nämlich gerade
riesen zoff um kuba und vielleicht ein
showdown zwischen ihm und dem
prominentes die rechtsextremen in der
partei bald auf dem parteitag in riesa
in sachsen nach der anfang vom ende der
afg was ist da eigentlich gerade los und
wer gegen wen und warum das versuche ich
in den kommenden ungefähr zehn minuten
mal zusammenzufassen
willkommen zur inside politik
[Applaus]
es läuft nicht für die afg sondern es
geht und zwar bergab ich habe nochmal
nachgeschaut dieses ist jetzt
tatsächlich die neunte mal in folge in
der bei der die afg verliert wenn man
die bundestagswahl mit nimmt sogar die
zehnte die sind seit november 2009 10
parteichef bei allen wahlen danach herr
kubala ab hamburg 2020 ginge immer der
balken nach unten hier nochmal ganz
übersichtlich da hat sich nämlich jemand
richtig viel mühe gegeben und alles
nochmal ganz liebevoll zusammengestellt
hier sehen wir die wahlen und wie viel
die afg jeweils verloren hat und unten
da sehen wir tino kubala ein paar
blümchen hatte jemand auch noch rein
montiert und ein schriftzug glückwunsch
steht das ist ironisch gemeint denn das
vielleicht interessanteste an dieser
grafik sie wird innerhalb der afg
verschickt da koffern manche mit
komplett offenem visier gegen den
eigenen parteichef nicht nur mit
anonymen grafiken nein auch direkt vor
der kamera hier denke ich auch tino
keller mit den aufgaben die er als ein
spezieller partei übernommen hat und
auch in der fraktion doch jetzt ein
punkt erreicht
wo er schauen muss dass es zu einer
veränderung kommt nicht überfordert zu
werden ich bin tatsächlich der meinung
dass aufgaben nicht gewachsen ist und
die rolle nicht richtig ausfüllt und wie
auch deswegen verlieren offener ausstand
gegen den parteichef sogar aus dem
bundesvorstand das ist ein ding vor
allem seine zu freundliche haltung
gegenüber russland wird kupa jetzt
vorgeworfen wie so viele andere in
seiner partei auch vadruper immer schon
ein großer freund russlands 2020 wurde
er in moskau sogar vom russischen
außenminister lawrow iv empfangen man
saß mehrere stunden zusammen diese
freundschaft scheint auch durch den
russischen überfall auf die ukraine
nicht wirklich getrübt zu sein beispiel
sondersitzung des bundestages drei tage
nach kriegsbeginn kam das parlament hier
in berlin zusammen russische panzer
rollten da längst durch die ukraine es
fielen bomben erstarren menschen in
dieser sondersitzung bedankte sich de
luca und zwar ausgerechnet bei russland
bedürfen gerade in diesen tagen
russlands beitrag für deutschland und
europa eben nicht vergessen auch dadurch
wurde vor 32 jahren die deutsche einheit
ermöglicht untermauert durch den abzug
russischer truppen im jahr 1994
dem müssen wir respekt zollen und das
sage ich ganz bewusst auch aus
ostdeutscher wir danken russland bis
heute dafür nach diesen und anderen
ähnlichen äußerungen gab es wahlen eine
im saarland verluste für die fdp sich
holstein da flog sie aus dem landtag und
eine in nrw da hat sie ist zwar wieder
rein geschafft aber nur so gerade eben
schuld daran copala und sein herz für
russland sagen einige auch ganz offen
vor der kamera ich beklage von anfang an
dass viele äußerungen aus unserer partei
dazu geeignet sind die russische
aggression in irgendeiner form zu
erklären bis hin zu gar zu entschuldigen
und das geht gar nicht einen kurs der
uns zu nahe in die nähe von la france
von putin bringt liegt weder im
deutschen interesse noch gewinnen wir
damit wahlen und die wähler an die wir
wollen kuba sieht jetzt ab gar keinen
grund sich irgendeinen schuhe anzuziehen
und schlägt gegen seine kritiker zurück
auf sehr spezielle weise das ist wie
früher beim camping ich vergleiche das
immer so haben sie immer diejenigen
beschwert das ist nass im zelt sind ist
und es waren diejenigen die auch ein
zelt hinein gepinkelt haben
interessanter vergleich mit seiner
partei oder auch darüber ist die nicht
gerade begeistert das ist nicht das
niveau das ich von afg kenne die
parteien die ich angetreten bin das ist
eine andere partei man soll das
bundesvorsitzender in der
bundespressekonferenz so nicht reden das
ist nicht das was wir als bürgerliche
alternative für deutschland sagen dass
wir sind nicht auf irgendeinem zeltlager
von wem auch immer sondern wir sind eine
bürgerlich konservative partei und da
haben wir in anderen sprachgebrauch
klingt so als könnte da demnächst ein
posten frei werden einer bringt sich
jetzt schon mal in stellung einer aber
nicht irgendjemand vielleicht ist es
jetzt an der zeit der von brandner im
bundesvorstand auch gesellschaft zu
leisten der nächsten legislatur
vielleicht die parteiführung auf
bundesebene auch mit zu prägen dafür
brauche ich eure stimme jan hacke gegen
den einst ein parteiausschlussverfahren
lief achtung spoiler erfolglos und vor
dem sogar die einstige fdp chefin frauke
petry die anderen parteien warnte die
verhelfen damit sie alle auch hier kann
birkenhake an die afg spitze
vorzudringen und jetzt glauben sie ja
nicht dass das gut wäre denn während die
afg aktuell führungslos ist und keine
strategie hat und stagniert obwohl sie
massenweise steilvorlage jeder sei es
geboten bekommen wird das unter brücken
nicht mehr passieren
seine berater haben eine strategie sie
haben eine vision und sie werden zwar
nicht demokratisch aber die afg am ende
einen das hier ist das gutachten des
bundesverfassungsschutzes mit dem der
geheimdienst erfolgreich begründet hat
warum er die gesamte afd als
rechtsextremistischen verdachtsfall
beobachten will 1000 seiten meine
kollegin julia klaus hat es geschafft
das als streng geheim eingestufte papier
zu bekommen rund 1000 seiten hat es wie
gesagt und höckers name taucht sage und
schreibe 4 169 mal darin auf zum
vergleich die lokale 51 mal auch kein
ruhmesblatt aber ja doch ein unterschied
werke selbst gilt nicht mal mehr als
verdachtsfall wird beim
verfassungsschutz als gesichert
rechtsextremistisch geführt und als
solcher beobachtet sogar auch außerhalb
seiner parlamentarischen arbeit im
landtag von thüringen
das passiert nicht so häufig als ich den
präsidenten des
bundesverfassungsschutzes kürzlich
nachrücke gefragt habe ließ die antwort
jetzt auch keinen großen
interpretationsspielraum
der rechtsexperte will also vielleicht
antreten das ist neu bisher hatte er das
gar nicht nötig hat er uns journalisten
gegenüber immer wieder behauptet so wie
hier auf dem parteitag in braunschweig
ich habe jederzeit die möglichkeit meine
stimme zu erheben und so wird
deutschlandweit gehört ich muss nicht
bundesvorsitzenden dieser partei sei
nicht für das was dieser partei nutzt
und werde vielleicht auch mal für dieses
amt kandidieren wenn ich die zeit für
reif halte das scheint jetzt der fall zu
sein höcker will aber wenn dann nur
alleine führungsfigur der afg werden für
den parteitag in riesa in sachsen liegt
ein antrag vor die doppelspitze
abzuschaffen wenn helge meint er müsse
als bundessprecher antreten und wir
hätten eine einer speziellen wird der
gegen kinox palla antreten müssen es
könnte also zum showdown kommen in riesa
und vielleicht zum anfang vom ende der
afd denn es wäre ein showdown zwischen
den rechtsaußen und den im vergleich
dazu nur der rechten in der kfd wenn der
rechtsextremist hatte die partei führen
würde dann hätte das wohl ziemlich
krasse auswirkungen weiter nach rechts
rücken könnte die partei dann ja kaum
noch viele derjenigen die sich jetzt
noch als gemäßigt bezeichnen würden die
partei dann wohl verlassen sogar enge
vertraute höckers äußern sich deshalb
gerade auf feind zurückhaltend ich hätte
es eine person natürlich und sie tragen
ja nicht jetzt auch dazu bei die
hochgradige polarisiert aber der
bundesparteitag ist bei uns sehr weise
wie ein hirte ist ja auch kein dummer
mensch und der wirt einschätzen können
ob er antritt für wasser antritt und
letztendlich dann der bundesparteitag
entscheiden afg chef höcker ganz
auszuschließen ist das wie gesagt nicht
sicher aber auch nicht wir waren schon
auf mehreren parteitagen auf denen
geraucht wurde vielleicht tritt man ist
nie passiert und ist auch dieses mal
nicht gesichert aber so konkret wie
dieses mal war es eben auch noch nie wie
sagte hüppe selbst einst im interview
mit meinem kollegen david gebhard dasser
gewütet abbrach bei david ihnen mit
zitaten aus seinem leben konfrontiert
hatte die auch für die
verfassungsschützer sehr interessant
waren
werde ich auch mal eine interessante
persönliche politische person in diesem
lande könnte doch sein vielleicht aber
hält sich auch kuba an der spitze und
findet jemanden an seiner seite er wäre
dann aus sicht der meisten delegierten
auf dem parteitag vielleicht das
kleinere übel nicht so extrem wie hocke
und nicht so unbekannt wie viele andere
die sich jetzt gegen ihn auf lehnen wir
hören von sehr vielen gesprächen die
momentanen geführt von teams die
zusammengestellt werden von versuchen
die einen oder die anderen zu verhindern
so oder so der parteitag wird super
spannend was meint ihr ist es sowieso
egal wer parteichef wird hertha copala
oder sonst wer geht die afg sowieso
ihrem ende entgegen schreibt es in die
kommentare ich freue mich auf eine
diskussion und las gerne ein leichter
abonniert uns wenn es euch gefallen hat
bis zum nächsten mal